what's the best way to fight a war
Afghanistan is now America's longest war
ever President Trump says he'll send in
more soldiers but this man says that's
not the route to victory I've laid out
this plan this alternative that comes in
at less than 8% of what the Pentagon is
spending Erik Prince founded Blackwater
a private military contractor
contractors trained people how to shoot
accurate respond to dangerous situation
this is a promotional film for the
contractor that now owns princes old
training ranges the US military pays
private contractors to do all kinds of
things provide security deliver mail to
remote bases send them back up to rescue
soldiers the government admits that
private contractors do the jobs well
often for half what the military would
spend we did a helicopter resupply
mission where we embarked our
helicopters on board a US military
supply ship we showed up to do that job
with two helicopters and eight people
replacing the Navy who was doing it with
two helicopters and 35 people why would
the Navy use 35 people the Admiral that
says I need 35 people to do that mission
didn't have to pay for them and when you
get a free good you use a lot more of it
government not only wastes money it does
things slowly in Afghanistan right now a
troop in contact fighting for their
lives can't drop a bomb without a lawyer
sitting in Qatar a thousand plus miles
away to give them permission to drop
that bomb and it's just not a serious
way to wage war fair but that's done
because bombs were dropped in the wrong
place
killing civilians and we made new
enemies war is hell
war is risky and it's dangerous but if
we're gonna entrust our people to put
them into harm's way you have to have
the confidence to back them up to
support them doing it bureaucracy also
makes it hard for the military to adapt
to changing threats we've spent close to
a trillion dollars largely using
equipment that was designed to fight
against the Soviet Union but it's been
misused fighting against pickup trucks
and people living in local villages you
think if you spend a lot to get the
Soviets it would
work on terrorists a supersonic jet
that's designed to go state-on-state and
with with standoff missile capability
all the rest is not necessary for
finding effective the enemies that are
living in caves or operating from pickup
truck it's a totally different military
adjusts no they do not clearly in 16
years of warfare the army has never
adjusted how they do deployments they've
never made them smaller and more nimble
you could actually do all the
counterinsurgency missions over
Afghanistan with propeller-driven
aircraft President Trump decided not to
take princess suggestions I think I know
a reason why people just don't like you
don't like the idea of mercenaries the
media doesn't like markets period but
markets have a way of providing things
when government can't the Flying Tigers
in World War two before America entered
World War two some American pilots made
extra money fighting the Japanese in
China these flying Tigers were
considered heroes they even made a John
Wayne movie but back then it was not
such a disparage topic always in fact
mercenaries helped create America
Jamestown Plymouth Massachusetts Bay all
paid for private security in the
Revolutionary War the Continental
Congress authorized privateers privately
owned boats to fight the British ships
privateers rated 600 ships and kept the
loot
although most private contracting has
gone well in Iraq there were violent
exceptions Blackwater security guards
shot more than 30 unarmed Iraqis 10
years ago security guards from the firm
Blackwater opened fire on a crowded
square in Baghdad 14 Iraqis civilians
died for princess soldiers were
convicted of voluntary manslaughter the
fact is the guys did more than a hundred
thousand missions protected missions in
dangerous war zones and less than 1/2 of
1% of all those missions to the guys
ever discharged a firearm wholesale
corruption and finally murder a
full-fledged criminal enterprise grossly
inaccurate and sad thing is
the hardcore anti-war left went after
the troops in Vietnam in the Iraq war
largely Afghanistan they went after
contractors they killed so many innocent
civilians in so many different areas
contractors providing a good and service
to support the US military mission
vilified demonized because there are
for-profit companies prints eventually
sold Blackwater they came up with a new
idea
fighting pirates remember that Tom Hanks
movie about a ship hijacked by pirates
such piracy was once common the film the
Somali project documents Prince's plan
to create a private army that would
fight pirates he got the United Arab
Emirates to fund it the establishment
hated the idea the UN called it a brazen
violation of its arms embargo but prince
went ahead anyway now we're gonna start
out the private army went after the
hijackers bases will cease three
different objective areas the cameras
caught that as it happened whatever
pirates came close to shore the
mercenary army attacked they freed lots
of people who'd been held hostage by
pirates in a few years the private army
plus private ship owners finally arming
themselves drastically reduced piracy in
2010 Somali pirates took more than a
thousand hostages in 2014 no hostages
did you know about this I didn't it got
no publicity the media do not want to
report good things about private
militaries you've had all the success
you've made money doing things more
efficiently but I would say most
Americans hate you for it
they despise Eric Prince a most
notorious defense contractor of them all
Blackwater and its founder Eric Prince
Prince he really is the poster child for
everything wrong about the military
Coughlin's just horrible it's largely
ignorance okay this idea that it's
immoral to try to make money or to try
to innovate or to build a better
mousetrap
I mean innovation is what's made America
they say it's immoral to make money
killing people
well preparing US military people to do
the best on their mission is not immoral
what is there better solution their
solution is to take the profit out have
it run by government and that's why we
spent close to a trillion dollars and
are still losing
you